you
[Music]
okay we'll start I guess we have a full
new room now
good afternoon my name is Ajay Kumar I'm
a researcher at the adaptive systems an
interaction group at Microsoft Research
and today I'm very proud to have three
amazing speakers talking about human AI
collaboration and Barbara growth
yesterday gave a great keynote kicking
us up on this topic and what kind of
capabilities do we need from systems
that are going to be collaborating with
humans and have it is different than
systems that are just going to
accomplish some tasks on their own and
this topic is becoming even more
critical for us at Microsoft where our
one of our missions now is augmenting
human intelligence through AI so we are
going to start by having three short
talks from Eric orbits from melandsam
Bay and from rocket Parvati on on their
research but then we are going to have
at least half an hour at the end of the
session discussing what they talked
about and other things maybe that didn't
come up during the talks so please think
about what questions you have for the
speakers if you have something
particular for them we are going to
accept a few questions after their talks
but please think about what are the
harder questions you would like to ask
to all three speakers for the keep them
for the end of the session so we are
going to start with air Corbett Eric
doesn't have an introduction he's been
introduced a few times already at least
twice and two more introductions are
going to come this afternoon but Eric
orbits is is a technical fellow at
Microsoft and also he is managing labs
MSL AI that's it
that's it and I group are you really
that consistent an interaction so thanks
but by the way the next two sessions I'm
introducing other people so I think I'm
sharing them so I thought I'd just be
very brief today but it's just a
amplifier a couple things I said
yesterday and point out some great
opportunity areas for building deeper
human AI collaboration models of people
and tasks model complementarity and
coordination of initiative there's a
whole community called user modeling and
even that community I think is just
barely scratched the surface about what
it means to build with our
representations and our inference
machinery systems that could continue to
operate side-by-side with people as they
work on tasks and both interpret the the
state of a task as well as human goals
and needs if you can do that well you
can imagine you can do all sorts of
things and over the years we can go
through a long list of our attempts to
build user models probabilistic user
models that could take desktop activity
data structures changing States in
various kinds of software including
Microsoft Office software like Excel for
example and that would compute
probability distributions over things
like goal sets of goals users might have
over time and sequences of goals tasks
competencies particular needs for
decision support for example I decided
to keep the all these some of the
examples out of the deck right now I
want to just mention these high-level
principles and then show some videos and
have you think through what the videos
mean but the basic idea is you cannot
you can imagine you can sum some of the
work that I find the most interesting
dimension of this kind of effort in
modeling was building systems that can
model the world with lots of sensors and
then model human beliefs about the world
and then use both of those distributions
to to drive decision support I mentioned
yesterday is idea of complementarity I
like this picture where I think about
all of cognitive psychology over the
years identifying what makes us human in
terms of our cognition and our abilities
limitations across memory attention and
judgments among other areas ability to
obtain concepts visualization there's
great literature out there but ticking
through what's been done to date with
complementarity we again barely
scratched the surface
Ajay Kumar and I did some fun work a few
years ago with galaxy zoo where we
actually considered the competencies of
a vision system and detailed
competencies of different people coming
into a citizen science system to create
joins but here's an example of what we
see to be more popularly now so last
year there was something called the
chameleon grand challenge asking based
on a big data set of pathology slides of
lymph nodes can you build a system that
could detect metastatic breast cancer in
lymph node sections of the grand
challenge and of course normals and
metastatic cancer and the human the the
best automated system was that was it
was accomplished on neural network but
the human was superior but then in the
paper this last few paragraphs of this
paper after they celebrate their the
results and talk about the human being
superior they said well wait a minute if
we actually have a very simplistic
algorithm that combines the output of
the neural net and the output of the
human beings that they look to their
slides they can dramatically reduce the
error I may that's a dramatic reduction
in error for a lot of patients again
it's very simplistic approach without
thinking about the details what happened
in you know what's been going on you can
imagine going further if you actually
dug into the black box of the two
intellects and the combination of their
skills it's another example I think it's
interesting a - Marie Campbell
last year at a conference Marie Campbell
is on a deep blue team and so well here
we are today with chess if you look at
blitz five second per move blitz chess
30 second promote rapid chess classical
three minute remove and then correspond
this chest sorry it wasn't very familiar
with it it's like a parent Li three days
or more by you know email or post or us
post snail mail but the idea is that
human beings are in the blue here you
see that computers back in 1997 began to
dominate but look at the green here with
human plus computer what happens with
correspondence Jess for people have time
to think - and play with computers now
I asked Maria says
buddy ever built a computer system to
play chess that was built to augment
human chess playing versus just being a
chess playing machine
answer was no not that he knew of and my
thought was wow it's you can do that if
you built the machine that you know so
for example show a human being visual
search spaces in helping a human do AV
compares not just playing any games
wouldn't creature do much better with
that kind of a of a center like system
just a question that I have looking
forward so on complementarity of this
back to literature again there's really
fabulous cognitive psychology I want to
really promote again and again here for
example work by Sperling who had
consider a colleague now down in Irvine
and Milton we know both of AT&T Bell
Labs did work on something called the
attention operating characteristic curve
where they would give human beings to a
dual task challenge like to visual path
visual search tasks and push them hard
and give them an objective function and
find out what human beings could do when
it came to divided attention for example
and how this kind of knowledge could
help us think through for example
divided attention scenarios where we
demand users to deal with an alert and
back to their word document and so on
this is a little pen but this is a piece
of the tip of the iceberg of that work
now talking about the complementarity is
one piece right but then it's how do you
deliver how do you inject the intellect
into problem-solving with the human
being and this is coordination of
initiative how do you coordinate so the
way somebody use my blog I like to
thicken blobs I guess or maybe it's best
my artistry but here here's a problem at
the users focus of attention here
imagine a really smart computer somebody
that says hey I can actually I see that
blob and I can decompose it into
subproblems alpha and beta and I can't
touch alpha that's very human I know
that I can help you in beta though and
the whole communication strategy I'm
going to do I don't do beta alpha
let's move curse and could we build
systems to understand how to help
decompose and provide this a volley of
initiative in solving problems
subscribing to principles of compliment
air
and so on now it turns out that the
there's been some really nice work
some of it pretty formal by cycling by
psychologists who are psychologists of
conversation like herb Clark and they
talk about this idea of and they talk
about conversation but I let's us map
this to problem solving because it's
same kind of thing here and they talk
about in a conversation we've had
several people from the sig value
community here who know this stuff very
well does the idea of contributing to
the conversation with conceptually in a
back-and-forth volley this is her Clarke
and Duncan and Goffman and Goodwin but
here's what a picture that's often drawn
I think due to Clarke originally where
there's multiple layers anything's sort
of you to work on the ground with
another human human human they talk
about but let's talk about this with
human machine where channel is
established like we're going to we're
going to communicate now on talking to
you engagement there's a signal so the
signal detected let's say I'm talking to
you now the words are going are going a
big process there's an intention that's
the meaning behind the words and then as
the actual back-and-forth of volley of
what's expected who goes next who's
going to contribute who's going to
listen now this this multi-level process
and I'd like to look at the top piece
trail we name it flow of initiative for
any kind of AI human collaborative
system so I did great carries here which
Greg Greg so I'm on the advisory board
very proud of Johns Hopkins C s
Department and I can sort of lay some
pride in talking about some of the work
that you've done Greg woods with your
team here but let's go to health care
for a very concrete example of a
physical layout a physical example but
the metaphor is a metaphor for anything
any kind of collaboration but I love its
work by Carol Wiley and others I guess
she was a master student she did this
correct yeah so so what Carol and team
did is I looked into taking some imagery
of surgery and they feel reasoning about
a grammar of surgery one of the first
steps you need to sort of accomplish in
in getting in getting in coordinating
initiative would be the recognized state
and so the idea of being able to us in
hmm model they used to recognize a
reaching needle situation so it's a
human being doing this action and a
machine is recognizing this state of in
a surgical process inserts and left
transfer or loosening and if you knew
these states that I'm not sure when Greg
maybe can come it later about this how
much this has been used in actual larger
scale coordination but if you could
actually recognize state and you had a
robotic surgeon those going to work with
you
this was Children's Hospital like it's a
year and half ago and in science and
additional medicine paper work with you
on a repair social repair here humans
working with a machine this is an
anastomosis repair which is a very
complex complex repair surgery it's two
tubes can be sewn together like
intestines cut in the middle and
reassembled
but it's suggesting to say that there's
a robotic system that's looking at the
kind of the seams here and so on and
then to the back and forth kind of a
volley between the human and the Machine
and again I'm not sure how much
coordination machine is doing here but
you can imagine with this going someday
so I can show you it just a couple of
few videos now and if I go a little
faster a few videos and just this is
work with and Dan Bowen you down here
somewhere
yeah deaf man work with the Dan lit up I
think I need to click on these but we
put the trivia system that would provide
we speak you read about this work but
we're looking at coordination between
people and machines where IBM did the
Jeopardy system we did like they Trebek
moderator system right so so we're going
to give you the first view out to the
two individuals the or human subjects
will give us mission to release this and
their view from the machine in a second
here the red dot assistant gaze of an
avatar
so grain do you think save yes that's
run so far have one correct answers now
on to the next question
so that's the view when a machine out
now you get a better idea what's going
on here so far had one correct answers
now on to the next question in the US
the hospitals have a red cross what sign
did they use in the Arab world solid
blue circle is that correct no so what's
the correct answers red crescent moon
yes that's right so so just now she she
being very active Norfolk here turn to
the young man and said raise displacer
eyebrow and those very fluid did you he
agreed yes he knew what was going on and
he imagined signaling even subtle thing
but micro structure of signal can be
very important in collaboration here's
an example that highlights the
importance of miles of attention in our
AI systems from data coordinating with
people
damn it Eric are the actors here finding
something yes
could you tell me the room number or
person you're looking for 4800 to get to
4800 excuse me
what if you go along go along that
hallway I'm looking for 4300 so just a
little bit of an annotation here so here
is the attention of van and we're saying
here right now the system actually is
waiting but which long it times out and
then says excuse me
and now if you know it's going to wait
again but it could actually try to get
it can use a very interesting technique
from Goodwin it's going to stutter and
try to get attention back that was very
explicit in terms of the design of the
system and if you think that's a fact
saying here here is in the wild again
with permission that cool it's pausing
for the glance
excuse me can I can I help you find
something morning your unique direction
excuse me do you need directions ok so
here's another kind of signal that's
going on and again I'm going to ask you
what you like better at human beings
this is a multi-level a graph of
uncertainty over time interview over
time in several levels of a
conversational conversation for the
uncertainty a system has in visual the
visual signal what's being said the who
goes next in a conversation and here's
the other version of it now we use the
same kind of signals to drive facial
expressions to commit to transmit
uncertainty this is a system by my door
we call harmonica we have a male version
called Chad so it's very equal equal
representation here what's your facial
expression hi Dan are you here looking
for Zach yes are you here for the 2
o'clock meeting with Zach sorry did you
say you were here for the 2 o'clock
meeting with Zach yes is one of you John
yes sorry I can't tell who is speaking
when you stand so close together which
one of you said there John either right
hi John that is expecting you will you
be joining the meeting served sorry
will you be joining the meeting yes all
right I've let Zach know you will be
joining his meeting with John I'm sorry
I think that is running a little bit
late I'm pretty sure he's on his way so
I think what's interesting is um to
think that I loved the fact that we did
this was a Tomislav who is an intern by
working with us maybe it's at three
summers ago now it's kind of scary then
but with magical is that it's it's
entropy signals spread over variables of
uncertainty about what's going on
directly controlling musculature and I
love the fact we had this running you're
looking right down the heart of the
probability distributions and it looks
very natural and it really is doing what
people do when they communicate about
ourselves own uncertainty I thought I'd
end briefly by going back to my first
year at Microsoft we did a user study it
was the Microsoft intelligent assistant
study and we set it up pretty busy yet
we have Andrew cotton mitts who was a
became a GPM at office and finally
retired like maybe eight or nine years
ago he is playing the role in this case
did a whole weekend he studies in a
secret soundproof booth no secret
soundproof soundproof booth and he can't
he can't hear a DECT who's going to be
given an Excel task it she's like a
medium level Excel user she's given a
task on a page of paper we asked both of
them to basically do protocol analysis
to talk out loud about what they were
thinking and we asked and you do your
best to magically through an interface
you can type in help this person
complete their task
I want everyone as I play this a few
minutes about this play sink to
initiative complementarity and
coordination and what you would do what
kind of agent you would build to help
out this woman again because after this
week we did a full full report on what
we learned was that there was any
interesting in terms of the findings we
both here
[Music]
and this person's very good at keyboard
shortcuts or they're very proficient
with collections but they need help
there
not sure they did with that they're kind
of Center center to that I wish I could
see their whole sheet all at once okay
right so I'm going to give them a
correction that they can just drag that
wrong column headers you can go down to
a little space here
don't nothing inside might have once
that's beautiful one of just good they
were just trying to run Arbor to change
the height or fluid look they're good to
go
you just drag the row okay now they're
up to
I'm not sure that that applies to this
task
what if they'll trying to come okay I'm
going to do that here you're trying to
refine if you try to combine multiple
you keep one to file
while they're doing it they must want to
do that alright nothing
yeah anyway it was really watched hours
these videos and watch when people did
sink it was amazing because then they
started like they're doing it and they
were sort of signalling back and forth
and you can tell there was a sink but
before the sink would happen to be all
this guessing in the Noah this is
distracting it's like a paper clip of
some kind which actually came out of
this work anyway so okay so I'll stop
there but I want to just leave you with
this these these examples thank you so
we have time for one or two questions if
you have anything specific to ask to
Eric yeah David so I'm you're talking
several I've seen earlier today sort of
look at two more human-like behaviors
and sort of see me simulating human
behaviors in order to get users
attention get them to behave certain
ways and it's got me wondering whether
that's that's going to also come with
perhaps costs like suddenly people are
going to invest time in being polite to
an entity which it's not helping that
entity when you're being polite to them
and it may be slowing you down or making
you frustrated or something I'm okay I
just go there first comment there's no
notion of us trying to people was trying
to be fluid and be more natural likely
meticulous right I understand that that
fluidity was sort of through trying to
get the system to to act like a human so
that people would would respond to it in
sort of humanistic ways I'm wondering if
there are more fluid ways if you're
going to treat if you want to treat it
as a tool instead of simulating a human
being does that does that increase the
fluidity or decreases it's a good
question David I think that them I could
have picked an examples of putana
circles floating through the walls we
have these ambient projects now that
have a really fun cortana circle that on
the wall and it has different kinds of
symbols coming out of it and the whole
idea of whether it's really I think it's
a separate issue I was trying to more
focus on and maybe with these examples
you got thinking about the naturalistic
part but it's more the coordination the
signaling you can imagine LED lights
instead of eyebrows flashing and maybe
that we left distracting people maybe
some day you have to pick your interface
and some people want this morphic like
experience some people want the flashing
LED which is the attention light we've
had one of our projects was called deep
listener before deep learning was even a
big space it was like it was interested
deep blue and hal hal lens you know the
hell red lens of the how mm and it would
turn as we're talking to it would go
from green which meant with a shine on
it you know glass see like it would go
yellow slow down and turn and turn red
and we get confused to a turn different
color so I thought you watch this thing
and people that break it was a very
natural experience to have this like
expression map expressions and
uncertainty for the color of the lens
that's a good question okay let's thank
you Erica let's have our second speaker
our next speaker is Millman tombe from
University of Southern California in
addition to being a professor in the
engineering department he is also a
founding co-director of USC Center for
AI in society
Milind is the triple-a I follow and ACM
Fellow and I've been admiring Millan's
work since my early days of my PhD
because in addition to being a lot of
theoretical contributions to the field
he also have been very successful in
putting his work into the real world by
helping the coast guard to become more
secure you know delivering his ideas
into LAX Airport and also for
environmental protection
okay hello thank you for coming to my
presentation so I'm going to be talking
about the essential role of human
machine partnerships in domains of AI
for social good this is work that was
conducted at our USC Center for AI in
society and this is a Center that's a
collaboration between our School of
Engineering in our School of Social Work
I'm a co-director from the AI side and
Eric rice from Social Work is the
co-director from the Social Work side
our mission is to advance their research
driven by the 13 Grand Challenges of the
American Academy of Social Work and
social welfare I'm not listing all of
them there's only a few that I've listed
here but they include big things like
ending homelessness and achieving equal
opportunity and justice and so forth the
UN the international version of this is
the UN sustainable development agenda
now of course these are big big Grand
Challenges what can we practically do
and so I'm going to highlight three
major areas of work at our Center I'll
start with the work that we've been
doing for a building AI assistant for
low resource communities and here I'll
emphasize the word AI assistance because
we are building assistance decision aids
and so this is a concrete project here
is work with the homeless shelters in LA
one big challenge is spreading
information about HIV amongst homeless
youth harnessing their social network we
can show that AI algorithms are far more
effective in spreading such information
but not only is there a more spread of
information about HIV but we get to this
end state where these happy young people
that are shown here and I'll come to
this is an important point of this
research but there's other projects in
this area intervening for substance
abuse prevention suicide prevention and
so forth so that's one big area of our
work another is the AI assistance for
conservation and so one concrete problem
here is in work that we've been doing
the Wildlife Conservation Society and
Uganda wildlife Authority and this is in
Uganda they're trying to predict
Porter's place snares in order to trap
animals if we can predict accurately and
get rangers to patrol and remove those
snares we can potentially save lives of
animals we've done a long experiment
recently for example multiple months
where we've been able to successfully
predict such snares remove these snares
get poachers arrested and potentially
the save lives of animals there's other
projects for example drone patrols in
South Africa where we can detect where
poachers and animals are so we can send
rangers to try to interdict them in the
past we've run projects with the US
Coast Guard to patrol in the Gulf of
Mexico against illegal fishing and intra
dict in illegal logging in Madagascar
with an NGO there a third area of our
work is AI assistance for Public Safety
and security this has been a
long-standing area of our work big
challenges that we have large number of
targets not enough security resources
how do you schedule or plan or allocate
limited resources we are appealing to
game theory and solving a large-scale
game we can then create patrolling
schedules this is for example our
algorithms that work around the Staten
Island Ferry these Coast Guard boats
that patrol that completely changed the
way how the Coast Guard used to patrol
this this is a salt after solving
spatiotemporal game you get a patrol
schedule and the Coast Guard I've been
running this and this is the same
algorithms that have been used by the
Federal Air Marshal Service to assign
air marshals to flight by different law
enforcement agencies in the LA area so
and we're happy to see several of our
collaborators now picking up this work
whether in Israel to monitor traffic and
Singapore to patrol the ports in the US
Irish Airport was funny when we were
funny or not but we were in the each guy
and you know Cyrus and the airport was
patrolled using software based on our
ideas by the University and you know
Cyrus so these are three major areas of
work that we have ongoing my point here
today is to emphasize that in doing this
work there's really a human-machine
partnership that we have to emphasize
for example you'll see in the work the
social workers do their tasks and the AI
system does
let's ask the partnership is not only
between individual users and software
it's also with the organizations and so
this work requires us in low resource
communities to partner with homeless
shelters at the same place for you to my
friend's place in my LA area for
wildlife conservation it's organizations
like WWF WCS and then Public Safety and
security agencies like TSA and the u.s.
Coast Guard and other law enforcement
agencies in this talk i'll primarily
focus on our work on low resource
communities and I'll start with a small
video clip from our work to highlight
the role of my PhD student among other
hooded majority of the work and Eric
rice my collaborator on this work at the
USC Center for artificial intelligence
in society we are researching ways to
leverage the power of social networks to
address complex social problems my
colleagues and I have focused in one
particular problem how to use artificial
intelligence techniques to prevent the
spread of HIV among homeless youth in
Los Angeles County homelessness has
reached a crisis level with nearly
47,000 people experiencing homelessness
on any given month homelessness is and
has to be our top priority after all
real lives are on the line sometimes
overlooked in this conversation is the
increasing number of homeless youth
there are up to six thousand homeless
young people sleeping on the streets in
Los Angeles these homeless youth are 10
times more likely to be exposed to HIV
due to high-risk activities such as
unprotected sex and needle sharing among
house.you less than 1/2 of one
have HIV get among homeless youth nearly
10 percent are back there educating all
these youth about HIV is a necessity but
this goal is unachievable due to limited
resources so I'm going to get to what we
do about this but as you can see since
you are close to Hollywood this was our
attempt to be Hollywood and so when I
took this video full video and showed it
to my family
the response was please don't do this
again this is not for you but but we did
submit the whole video to triple-a I
triple era viewers fortunately only
focused on the technical aspects and not
on our acting and so this worked out
well for us so the challenge here is
that we are given a social network this
is not a Facebook network but this is
actually face to face network of these
homeless youth observed by social
workers this is full of uncertainty and
we have a capacity limit so we can only
bring in let's say five views at a time
we so we brought them in we've selected
them carefully and now there's a
education session where our social or
colleagues educate them about sexual
health and condoms and how to
communicate this information with their
peers this is a peer led intervention
because these are homeless youth they're
untrusting of adults and therefore this
has to be done by peers so our so this
is this is how this session on force so
it's a whole long day session they now
are free to go out and spread this
information among their peers but in
return they also give us information
about the network I'm friends with so
I'm so so I'm so it's connected to
so-and-so so we get more information
about the graph and that means that we
can now be more clever about the next
five youth that we will select for
intervention and then again the same
process unfolds we get more information
and then we bring in the next five youth
and so the process is a dynamic process
where we gather more information it's
not a one-shot a single short decision
problem and so it's influenced from
influence maximization in a dynamic
uncertain fashion and this problem can
be solved as a pom DP and essentially
the homeless shelter is running this
adaptive policy it chooses youth when we
act they get to get us more information
and that
means that this policy can then select
the next five youth the AI problem here
is of course solving this massive palm
BP I wouldn't have time to really go
into how we generated this algorithm but
that's the technical contribution now
let's look at what happens first let's
look at it in simulation these are two
graphs homeless youth graphs on the
y-axis is the amount of indirect
influence the non peer leaders who would
be reached by our algorithm and the to
dark green lines these green lines this
is our algorithms to call it healer and
the others our baseline the gray in
particular is degree centrality bringing
in the most popular youth for
intervention you can see that in
simulation the you know the bigger green
lines are much higher so this showing
that there's promise in our algorithm to
do better well what will happen in
practice and so we did a pilot test
bringing in 170 homeless youth 16
roughly in each condition to under the
AI conditions and one in degree
centrality bringing in the most popular
youth and so this is the traditional
method of how they spread this
information about HIV and so the way
this would work is we get a preliminary
network from social workers we run a
healer it will say bring in these five
youth in this case these four youth they
give us more information about the edges
in the network then we bring in the
healer runs again brings in the next
four youth and in this way we got 12
youth to spread information about HIV in
this network so we did this and the
question now is who got the who got two
more youth in the process so we are now
looking at non peer leaders the people
we did not bring in for intervention the
AI algorithms a healer and healer plus
plus as shown reach about 70% of the non
peer leaders the traditional method
degree centrality F are the popularity
approach it reaches up just about 25% so
clearly the AI algorithms are able to
reach a larger fraction of the non peer
leaders but does this getting this
information actually lead to changing of
behaviors and here it's showing if you
look at the proportion of the dark green
bar that got started that started
testing for HIV again again with AI
algorithms Allah
a fraction of you started testing for
HIV and with the earlier approach here
we got no convergence starting to test
for HIV so why does this happen and this
is an important point these AI
algorithms are looking for people in far
corners of the network the popular
approach the heat degree centrality
approach it sort of hangs brings in
people who are well connected to each
other so if you look at the percentage
of edges between peer leaders themselves
these are useless edges they don't
really transfer useful information
because there are among peer leaders we
are already bringing in for intervention
so this degree centrality here is like
20% with healer and healer plus plus
they are going too far corners and
therefore they don't have edges amongst
these peer leaders and that's saving and
that's very important because that
information transmission is not wasted
it's another way to look at it if there
are different communities in the network
with these AI algorithms you are getting
coverage across different communities
and with this most popular approach we
are not why is this important I'll come
to that in a minute but let me first
show you a testament from our partner
alison her staff safe place for you
beautiful way to kind of like marry this
tech world with the social service world
like and how we can we can kind of go
deeper and impact young people and
elevator if this group became a really
big thing it can really help out a lot
of youth and so the next step here
having done this pilot test is to do
this test with 900 youth and this has
already begun 300 and all done different
conditions e-learning plus plus 3 in no
condition null condition and three with
300 with the most popular approach now
let's come back to this picture of the
smiling youth so one of the things that
was very interesting that we noticed is
that people who are selected by these AI
algorithms there's actually a different
kind of an impact on them in fact some
of these people actually change their
turn their lives around the felt
empowered they have stable jobs these
youth in particular have houses and so
forth and so my colleague
laboratory tries fine points out that
picking youth as peer leaders was
changing their self-esteem and a sense
of confidence so we often talk about AI
algorithms bringing in biases that are
negative here's a bias that's been
brought in by this AI algorithm that's
positive these were youth that were not
traditionally seen by the housing agency
these are not people who were spotted by
the homeless shelters they were in the
far corners but they were playing an
important role and these AI algorithms
picked them up and and in this way
actually helped them change their lives
so I think this is a we have to be
careful when we talk about biases
because the biases can go both ways
there's a lot of other work that's going
on in the center I'm not going to be
able to cover everything
for example substance abuse prevention
again using social network trying to
help with suicide prevention matching
homeless youth to homes in LA this is a
project that started this summer trying
to think about North Korean refugees
settling down in South Korea modeling TB
spread in India and modeling gang
violence in Los Angeles I wanted to very
briefly in one or two minutes also talk
about a completely different problem and
a completely different kind of AI
assistant and here I wanted to talk
about wildlife poaching in Uganda with
our colleagues in wildlife conservation
society and Uganda wildlife Authority I
just highlight main results so this is a
beautiful place this Murchison Falls
National Park where wonderful animals if
there's threats to wildlife snares
thousands of them that get placed to
attack these animals so our task is to
predict given a grid over the park in
each grid square how likely is it that
the poachers would attack they are given
these features and we're trying to
predict where snares would be placed so
that Rangers could remove them and thus
save these animals so this is first just
showing you in simulation this is
training data or past several years and
looking at what would happen in how well
would we predict attacks in 2015 and the
dark green bar is our best model you can
see that it's significantly more
accurate compared to others
machine learning models that we threw at
this problem but this is this was a
simulation we also did tests in the wild
and so this is we tell them okay go to
find these snares and here for example
this Ranger has found the snare consider
this is not a very easy task than going
out to find these nests but helping them
locate this is important and so we chose
2/9 square kilometer areas in our pilot
tests where we predicted hot spots which
they were not patrolled and so we said
here's where you go and you find you
will find snares and they hadn't
patrolled these areas frequently before
and we were pretty good in predicting
what was going to going on in these a
poached elephant for some we were too
late to save this elephant but next they
found the whole snare snare roll of an
elephant so what this means is that
poachers were active in this area they
were poaching elephants but before the
next elephants could be killed we were
able to remove these snares and
hopefully save lives of elephants we
also found an antelope snares here a
next test was a six-month test where we
created these 27 different areas of 9
kilometer square each some were
predicted to be high some were predicted
to be low and the goal here was to get
the Rangers to what these and find
snares the Rangers didn't know which one
was which meaning which were predicted
to be high attack areas and which were
to be low and we found our catch per
unit effort this is the way we measure
this number of snares found per
kilometer in the high area was 0.11 in
the low area 0.01 tenfold difference so
we were pretty accurate in predicting
where snares would be found the
traditional the historical catch per
unit effort is 0.04 so certainly we seem
to have helped these Rangers there's the
other side effects so when the Rangers
went out in this area they would find in
one case they found a trail they chase
the tree they pursued the trail found a
camp of poachers ambushed the camp
arrested poachers confiscated wire
snares and so forth there are many
interesting find
things along the way but let's let me
now wrap up and talk about what we have
learned in general in in this area it's
really important to build these
partnerships between humans and machines
humans focus on their expertise in AI
assistants on their humans social
workers will talk to homeless youth
about use of condoms and so forth and
the AI algorithms are figuring out which
nodes to select in a social network to
transmit this information in building
these assistants there's got to be a
right path division for human versus
machine the AI algorithm is saying okay
within this one square kilometre area
you are going to find snares but whether
it will be hidden under this bush or
this tree well that's the that's what
the ranger would know and that's what
they they focus on so we leave each with
the particular expertise that they have
but there's also this notion of
adjustable autonomy and we have to be
right about this in the sense that if we
say human is always right that's not
going to work as I showed the wrong
biases that human bring to the table and
so sometimes you really want the
machines the AI to override what the
human is really trying to do
and finally interpretability
transparency this is really important
you know even the homeless shelter wants
to know why did you select these youths
and not others
finally the search I mean one of the
questions that AJ asked was you know how
how would we make these implementations
really work and one of the important
points is the partnership is not between
only the AI and the user the particular
user but it's also a partnership between
us as researchers and organization that
we're trying to implement this in
immersion within the organization has
helped open our eyes to the challenges
that really face and the trust that gets
built up the other thing we notice of
course is having a champion on the
inside of these organization has really
helped us in getting these getting the
software out there so I'll end by saying
the tremendous potential for AI for
social good
wanted to come to our website that case
taught us C dot e-d-u thank you we can
get a few questions if you have anything
you want to say urgently David if nobody
else is going to ask questions I'm happy
to so it was beautiful work to show how
you could sort of have this impact on on
the students on the homeless youth that
you brought in beyond the effect that
had on other people but is that bringing
them in meant that you didn't bring in
some other ones right so I mean so
there's some ethical questions there and
also I mean these sort of battling
utilities for four different
participants how did you sort of weigh
that no I think this has really been a
surprise to us I mean the whole point
originally was um first of all thank you
for your comments the original idea was
this is purely a way of spreading
information about HIV and it was just a
surprise that the people that were
brought in with the traditional methods
did not have this kind of an impact but
the ones that were being brought in by
the pom DP planners seemed to have
change you know behave differently they
have become more responsible my
collaborator tells us a very interesting
story of how this youth that we've
selected the homeless shelters at KU
this this person you're using this
person as a peer leader but then when
when he was actually called he was all
you know the sober and and really ready
to go
activated and not only did he do his job
but also that seemed to have turned his
life around in terms of him finding a
stable job so there's something else
going on here that we don't completely
understand but it's an interesting thing
to say we're you know that this is this
is a situation where there is some nice
bias something that the humans were
overlooking that the eye algorithm had
picked up on but you're right
there are more complicated issues here
that need to be
understood but we are at you know where
are the beginning stages is at least
good to see this effect so far yes
that's the most interesting part so
they've been cased as where we'll go and
say okay there's two of them say the you
know you've been selected as a peer
leader and the other person will say
what about me is it well done algorithm
did not select you okay that's fine yeah
so it's a it's a it's not a human being
who did that so it can go both ways it
can go both ways so did you find any
interesting like a unique patterns among
these homeless people like they do have
their own communities or not that's
right so the actually they are these
graphs have a very particular structure
the youth that hang out together on the
beach the ones that play basketball so
there are smaller communities that are
tightly connected with sparse
connections to others and the the palm
DP algorithm the only way to scale it up
was really to exploit the fact that
there are these communities and that's
how we were able to scale it up and so
there is certainly structure in this
graph and there's a whole lot more that
can be done scaled these up harnessing
those to scale up these algorithms
do you think it would be possible to
take the same approach but in this case
tried to combat the spread of negative
information or fake news so if you were
looking at the dissemination networks
and understand where the best
intervention would be to try to provide
additional evidence to combat
misinformation certainly I guess the way
this whole war got started was a visit
to USC by a major who are serving in
Afghanistan and his problem was that he
had to take his 30 members of his unit
and spread information about you know
the US Army and say that you know to get
the villagers to not support the Taliban
and that was where you know this whole
work started and then it turned out
along the way that I met Eric and he
said well this work can be useful it now
we never got the data from Afghanistan
but we did get data for the homeless
youth so there's a significant potential
certainly for this kind of work
thank you our next speaker is camp
Romani Rao is the professor at the
Arizona State University and he is the
current president software player and he
is also involved in the partnership IFA
okay thank you for showing up so he is
very big business you know every day we
are just bombarded with news about AI so
for example you know you have like CNN
is reporting all sorts of important news
about like AI helping humans so you
don't believe me right I mean clearly
it's fake news the reason you know it's
fake news is not just because yeah I
can't be without drama but also because
we really never have news items about AI
helping people you know if you look at
the way we sum our lives it's more like
this right so essentially we take two
mundus pride when AI systems beat you
know humans every possible thing right
so for example for example we have an OB
beat Kasparov IV that's a lot of new
storage we be liberators the liberators
beat the poker dice that's another news
coverage alphago poor kg and literal
attitude great news coverage it's almost
as if you know yeah I have this curious
ambulance to human beings right so our
system seemed happier see the far away
from humans right even before even the
most recent AI you know hype you know we
had the spirit and robot just basically
taking over Mars right our of course in
adversarial stance with humans
so as the you know John Lennon said we
want to help humanity it's just the
people that we somehow can't seem to
stand right now this you know even when
we try to force robots to kind of work
with humans all sorts of interesting
things are happening like example we
force them to cooperate
they either seem to run over us are try
to commit harakiri so this is the kind
of situation that we are in and this has
been given lots and lots of trauma and
heartburn to important people like
obviously you know alarm us who is again
out there talking about how he is taking
over the world and you need to be
worried I mean honestly we need to stop
freaking out alarm okay because
otherwise none of you are going to get
your pre-order Tesla's right so we
really need to slow him down a bit so
it's important that we work on AI
systems that work with humans if for
nothing else to keep alarm be happy
right so you know back in last year when
I was running international joint
conference on AI so one of the things we
did was to have as the special team for
the conference of human evade artificial
intelligence systems and with with the
tag line that I intentionally design a
dystopian future and spend time being
all paranoid about it right so that was
part of the tagline and you know it
looks like and in fact there was a very
interesting set of activities along
around this
including a very nice panel that you
know Eric and the butler and other
people involved and in awful eternal
actually in fact there was some part of
it you know actually some people seem to
have gotten late in the news cycle like
human area I could save us from the Robo
collapse apparently this should you know
be an important thing to okay so and and
of course there are other places with
the human area sort of gotten back into
and you know human in the loop systems
have gotten back into sort of research
agendas Jason briefing that happened
last year I essentially brought up
important stuff for DoD to support human
AI interaction there was the preparing
for the future with AI report that the
Obama administration did that has a very
long discussion of important issues in
human with a I challenges okay so now
the interesting thing is why all this
why do we need affirmative action for
humans a very I systems why is it that
somehow that's not obvious and I think
exactly what was thinking about this
from the point of view of AI because
it's been the case that we somehow feel
that putting humans along with the AI
systems is sort of cheating we in the
back of our minds we feel that somehow
cheating and you know it doesn't help
that the very first human in the loop
system the Mechanical Turk they in the
loop system human actually was cheating
basically he was answering all the
question and I know for the longest time
in the beginnings of AI when there was a
human in the loop it was as a crutch to
a really badly designed AI system you
know in fact in planning my area we had
mixed initiative planning what it will
involve is humans actually going into
the bowels of the search cues of the
planners and trying to kind of ship the
search nodes around so that the planner
can somehow live to see another day okay
so this is a part of thing that we've
been you know coming from so like human
in the loop or human every eye is not
like the most obvious thing that we'll
be thinking about but so I think that in
fact it's important for us to
take a new look at this of course I mean
you know that we now have AI systems
that are in fact not powerful enough
that humans are no longer a crutch and
in fact taking humans into Lu expand the
enterprise of AI quite significantly
that's one of the things that I want you
to I want to constrain or push further
and then that it reduces some of course
the some of the octopus wallets about AI
and most importantly for the misaki's
which are researchers you know we really
want hard problems to solve and I can
tell you the large number of hard
problems that you're going to be taught
about when you're just thinking about
autonomous systems in fact I show this
to my students that the statement that
there is saying that this an almost Li
large brain that we have what we evolved
with them not to run away from the
Tigers of the savanna but to deal with
each other we are constantly modeling
each other's mental state and this is
why we need it especially the kinds of
things we have and so it seems to make
more sense that the general purpose a I
should really actually be thinking about
handling humans you know as partners
because that would be a lot more
interesting set of problems to solve
okay so even the intro to AI level
architecture of an intelligent alien and
I'm sure you many of you have seen this
as part about this so there is this
whole intelligent agent architecture the
moment you throw in and in fact to the
extent you know she's just focus on pure
economy when the humans the humans are
already determined as if they're like
inanimate parts of the environment but
if we start in looking at humans as
essentially with mental fears and
intentions and beliefs and desires which
is what you need to actually you know
interact with them all of a sudden the
identity decay becomes very more
interesting way more complicated you
know essentially everything that you do
you no longer are just worried about
what happens to the inanimate part of
the world which is also what happens to
the people's mental state you know how
do I do actions that will actually push
their mental state in the right
direction and so on so again this point
is that there is much bigger hope of AI
once you start looking at
in the room so that's sort of the thing
that actually thought that the first
part was to basically show that you know
it's like it's a bigger challenge to
look at humans in the loop it's not some
sort of a watering down of the AI dream
and then of course in my own group more
than the last like you know seven or
eight years we've been actually looking
we somehow discovered humans and we
started working with them and and so of
course these are my humans and my robots
and I'm sure you can figure out this is
nutritive anyway so the kinds of
problems that we look at in my own group
essentially include human in the loop
planning system so for example you have
inhibition planning being done by human
you know mission planners but with the
automated system looking over their
shoulder and try to suggest either
changes or to you know provide expansion
and to do this right essentially the
system needs to keep track of the
intentions of the human planet and and
also you know keep track of the mental
state that becomes important again this
is quite different from the old type of
mixed initiative planning systems where
essentially it was a human which is
helping the planner rather than the vice
versa so I like to say that in the past
we the humans used to go into the land
of planners but the whole point of AI is
to get AI machines to come into our land
not us to go into their land right and
then of course a more funny sort of
experiments are afraid even applications
that we look at human machine
collaboration in the context of human
robot collaboration so in this
particular case for example we have
intention recognition the human
intention recognition being done in this
case slightly more directly the people
are wearing emotive you know helmets we
just do very simplistic level of p300
brain signals and even that are enough
in some cases to get a sense of what the
human was looking at and you know what
in this particular case you know which
block does this guy want ourselves which
block does you want the robot to
actually pick so these are the kinds of
things that we can look at
and then there's one more since I'm
actually in Microsoft this is a hololens
which basically can be used in this
particular case the hololens is being
used by the robot to actually project
its intentions into the sort of the
visual field of the human soul so not
only the humans looking at the common
workspace but they're also getting some
additional information about what parts
of the work says that the robot wants to
get to you know so this above intention
recognition and projection is something
that's like a very important part of
collaboration we do that you know in day
to day typically we tend to do in a
multi-modal way so sometimes it will be
by language sometimes by gestures in
this particular case I just showed you
you know to specific augmented reality
style ways of doing that but now you
know we also look at for example the the
bigger sense of these sorts of you know
human robot collaboration in larger
scheme of things like for example
certain rescue scenarios so we actually
came up with like recently one time a
variety of scenarios in the
search-and-rescue domain which look at
different ways in which humans and you
know robot collaboration can be
facilitated and with increasing amounts
of technical difficulty so that sort of
thing also we look at and one last plug
in this case is to say that this I we we
have a paper round under an archive
talking about some of the challenges in
terms of this sort of you know agency
human aware a AI agents you know what
are the kind of questions that you look
at now talking about challenges in my
remaining few minutes I want to actually
mention some of the challenges from the
point of view of planning and then you
know and then sort of take any questions
so one of the biggest things you know I
as I said I'm mostly interested in
explainable most leaders in
agents working on a robotic agent bar
virtual agents working with humans and
so it's not just a one-shot thing it's a
more of a behavior being shown and the
question is how if a robot is especially
trying to come up with plans of action
normally it has its own model of
world I with respect to which it can
come up with an optimal plan the
difference when it is actually working
in the presence of a human is the human
has their own expectation of the model
the app capabilities of the robot which
is yourself you know mhm and the robot
is no longer just try to do what is
optimal with respect to its model but
also what is expected by the human
because of their approximation of its
capabilities so and in fact that leads
to two very interesting aspects if you
wind up doing what you are expected to
do then the humans are not spooked and
they find your behavior explicable so
its comprehensible to them so explicable
t involves as you see a robot trying to
make a plan a behavior that's not just
optimal with respect to M R but also
close with respect to what would be
expected from image and then sometimes
explicable T is impossible because it is
too costly to do what the human is
expecting you to do at which point they
might ask for explanations and when
there is an explanation required
explanation is not just talking to
yourself but really try to make sense of
why your behavior makes sense if only
the human can get a better understanding
of your capabilities so the explanation
dialog is all about getting the human to
come to the same page as you in terms of
your model okay so we actually look at
it that way so explanation as beyond
explanation as for elacry which is
essentially you can model some
comparison so with respect to that the
kinds of challenges we have include
interpreting you know what humans are
doing based on incomplete humans
reference and domain models and now this
is the incompleteness is something that
came up yesterday significantly that in
open worlds we have of course model set
incomplete you know you want to think of
openness open world talk to humans
because most of the time they don't know
exactly what they want so which is
actually partially specific references
and they have an approximation model of
what you are actually capable of that's
again in company and so in some sense
much of your behavior now has to be
taking into account these highly
partially and impartial models okay plan
with this kind of incomplete domain
models so explicable behavior and the
provide explanations as needed and when
you're providing explanations it's not
just soliloquy not talking to yourself
about your model and why you're right
with respect to your model but to
explain to the humans how they should
change their model of your capabilities
so that next time around an explanation
is not needed okay and then finally we
also look at understanding interactions
between humans and machines you have to
evaluate this so a bunch of you know
engineers sort of deciding what humans
would like and then providing in torino
sort of a design could be a bit of an
oxymoron and it is a a well developed
area human factors engineering and so in
fact it makes sense to what with them to
set up careful experimentation so in my
group I actually work with Nancy cook
one of my colleagues who is a human
factors Society president and actually
so we they wind up doing human human
experiments which we then bring forward
to learn lessons from them and then
actually design the planners which we
can then do additional human machine
experiments which all of which by the
way required IRB institutional review
board certifications AI people typically
don't even know what IRB stands for I
was one of them you know seven years
back and it turns out that it's really
hard to say that people should take us
seriously about how we are interested in
helping humans when we don't know what
IRB is because that's what you will wind
up needing if you actually work with
humans okay so that's that and I'm just
going to quickly make a couple of points
about the the challenges one of the
challenges I wanted to mention about is
this how to learn and plan with
incomplete domain models in the context
of planning in the context of planning
essentially we typically come with start
with very full part in a causal models
that's the way the typically the world
has been in planning but it turns out
that since the model that you are going
to use especially of the human
approximation of your capabilities they
are
not known to you you have to learn it
from indirectly from traces so we have
been looking at multiple aspects of math
models that can be learned more easily
including very shallow models
so in particular we looked at the idea
for example just using very shallow
models like action vectors where you
think of the planned behavior the
behaviors that you've seen as if there
are sentences in the vocabulary of
actions and then just apply word vector
methods so that all you will learn is
when you see this action after while
magically this action this other action
might occur now notice that you know
machine learning people have been trying
to go from revelational models towards
causal models so planning in my case i'm
going from causal models which are hand
given to correlational models because
they are easier to learn so it may well
be that some of us will be somewhere in
the middle but the point is that even
these shallow models can be useful in
actually about providing a proper
collaboration with the humans and in
fact one of the other things that we
showed in some work technically is that
given the same number of plant races
sometimes learning the shallow model and
using it might have a better performance
than learning a full model because the
full model mind self overfitting to the
data because it has too many more
parameters so that's something to keep
in mind in terms of explica bility one
of the interesting issues as i mentioned
is that you want your behavior that
you're showing to be closer to the
behavior that the human would expect if
they solve the same planning problem
with respect to their model and so it
involves not only just minimizing the
cost of the plan with respect to your
model but also minimizing the distance
between that plan and the plan that the
robot expects the human expects you to
do except the problem of course is the
humans model of your have abilities is
an unknown and you have to learn this
part from indirectly and so we wind up
actually learning it from the plant
races and for that we actually set up in
some cases we are getting either using
fastest way of getting places of you
know robot behaviors that you must find
the
so you can use that to for example learn
these types of references of course up
and in terms of the explanations itself
as I said we want to actually get the
humans model to come towards your model
and there's an edge guide paper that
will be presented in Melbourne that
talks about this as a search in the
space of models so that essentially the
explanation mouth if the deltas between
humans model and what it should have so
that the decisions that the robot has
made will actually become clearer so
this is sort of beyond explanations as
solid lastly where you don't just talk
to yourself saying look it makes sense
because my model says it's correct it
explanations are all about the beholder
model rather than about your own model
okay and then there is a lot of interest
in generally the bigger issue here in
terms of trusting autonomy in this human
machine collaboration Trust is is much
bigger complex issue there is a lot of
mechanisms about the long term trust but
at least the ability for an agent to
show explicable behavior and provide
comprehensible explanations is clearly
critical for engineering class so you
can lose trust very easily by part of
showing in some principal behavior but
you can gain trust hopefully by you know
on a longer term by you know incremental
progress so I mentioned already that I
work with human factors people in
setting up actual experiments in the
human loop that for the human human
studies we actually use a minecraft
before the project in the Baltimore
right now uses that so some years before
that we actually were using this
minecraft method and we run mint effect
human human collaboration experiments
that Nancy cook and her colleagues would
evaluate for variety of team fluency
issues which will then kit in decide
designing the planners and then we can
then redo those experiments with respect
to human machine
scenarios with one of these agents is
controlled by the human one is
controlled by the planners so I'm going
to end that basically there are a bunch
of technical issues in terms of at least
in the context of planned behavior
how does planning as a problem change
because there is a
in the loop with a different model of
your own capabilities and as a bigger
summary of the task as an apart one that
I would like to convince you that path
to general AI goes through human machine
collaboration really it's a and as a
bubble I was saying yesterday delete a
much bigger goal than can your robot
hang around in unmarked it's much harder
to hang around in the midst of us than
on Mars and then part two I try to tell
you some of the planning challenges in a
human machine collaboration that we've
been looking at and I'm going to stop
there and so please ask if you have any
questions for ro and in the meantime I'm
going to get Eric and milind to the
stage as well so that we can have our
general discussion any questions for owl
thank you forgot to introduce myself
last time Beth miner from Georgia Tech
but I've just have adored this session
so thanks to all of the speakers I love
your explanation that you give your
students which is you know the power
that we have here has evolved about
making sense of other human beings and
how that we really should pivot around
our orientation around AI challenges
perhaps a naive question but are people
working on systems that observe how
other human beings are observing a
person as additional inputs so for
example a security robot could be
observing someone and let's say an
airport but taking into account how 20
other people are also reacting to that
individual would be additional human
wetware into making sense of that
situation I think that's a perfectly
valid set of data together so in fact in
general in this area data sets are
reasonably spots in fact one of the
questions that they asked us to think
about is what data sets can be gathered
and put out there and if this is the
kind of data that would be very nice
together not just what the person one
person is doing but what the bystanders
are doing and it would be very useful
to capture pastor of a data and
hopefully we will but right now I don't
know of anyone with capturing that part
of it my home AI agent would just decide
to ignore me by watching the faces of my
children and if my children are nobody
made anyway be like yeah just find it
northa Thanks think of what comment best
is that in a situated interaction
project that I was talking about one of
the I consider the the probably the key
breakthrough in that project was
multi-party understanding many people
coming up to the system and their
relationships are making that
foundational target of representation
and reasoning who's talking to who when
was the talking going on between two
people versus the computer and so on and
so be certainly looking at multiple
people and what they were doing was part
of there's a reasoning process
absolutely you can imagine people like
you know Gregg's teams of you know
coordinating what happens in an
operating room what's going on who's
getting news talking to him yeah so
while that is the ultimate goal I just
want to challenge you to think a little
differently so I had a PhD student who
just finished Tulane short who actually
did exactly that she did multi-party
interactions with a robot observing and
moderating the robot never knew exactly
what the people were talking about in
fact who didn't even use any natural
language understanding we could but we
didn't it just looked at every other
back channel timing information and was
able to do things like moderate the
conversation and get people to be more
polite and in fact more kind to each
other and less competitive so I just say
that because I think there's this
upfront assumption that you have to do
you know kind of AI and reasoning to
achieve some of these goals and it's
really a combination of you know a lot
of back channel as well as you know what
are they saying who is talking there's a
lot more going on than the back channels
are part of depth and part of which
evidence we don't initially have to do
NLP to know who's talking to who and
even looking at face pose and so on so I
mean it's a it's a it's a it's your
traditional Bayesian fusion of many
signals so yes I would just say rather
than necessarily starting top-down you
could start the other way you can start
bottom-up and say if I don't even try to
understand what they're saying but I go
by these other metrics you might go far
it ends up sometimes coming up with a
very different solution so sorry
respect to your point I guess we already
one of the nice things about this second
system it has been I think by my count
there three panels um you know human a I
think's including in addition to the
great keynote speech and the one for
example and the emotions and the social
skills panel for example was focusing
much more on what can you do just by you
know looking at specific emotional cues
I think sometimes that is important but
it's there are also cases where you
actually should do in collaborative
problem-solving it's the entire behavior
it's not just trying to you know react
to a single emotional cue so the way I
exactly
yeah this is a wonderful session and I
think I have a recently I read an Apple
report it says that robots and AI
actually make social equality worse so
what do you think I would like to hear
about your views and if it's your it's
yes then what should we do and if it's
not why not thank you so you're talking
about robots making social inequality
words like ground robot source of white
robots or something at that time
basically I think it's missions about
because in order for you to acquire
knowledge of robots and AI you really
need more education also in this way
according to report no that's why I
would like to hear from yo from you and
see how would you say it I can send you
the URL and it's on my report okay so
let me let me take it in another
direction so I spoke with the first team
that was implementing you know
installing first IBM robot first IBM
computer in India so this was many years
ago and what their thing was okay you
know there's a factory where this had to
be installed and they were workers
outside and their whole thing was we're
going to lose our jobs we want to let
this in there's going to be all kinds of
problems and so they wouldn't let this
team in so during the festival when
these workers were out celebrating the
engineers went in they put the computer
in now maybe some people lost their jobs
right there and then but on the whole
this has really helped the economy it's
got you know a boom electoral booming
middle class and so on and so forth so
I'm not I mean you know this is a very
very complicated matter there's so many
different directions to take this in I
don't think there's a way you know like
a clear-cut answer here but I mean I
know
in the past when you have asked those
questions I guess in the spring when
Eric and I were on this panel and you
are talking about this in terms of
progress I mean the it's very gray right
as it sort of it's not really clear
which where this is going to go but I
don't think we can necessarily say it's
definitely going to get worse so I think
another point that actually one of the
questions that AJ I've brought up for us
is are the tasks where essentially
humans and robots have to work together
we really humans can just completely be
removed and robots can do everything and
that sort of plays into this because to
some extent you know parts of the work
that the words are doing my presumably
be kind of making somebody else
unemployed but the way I see it is
essentially the collaboration
collaborative human AI interaction is a
more interesting one because it's less
about loss of jobs and more about
effectiveness of what we do you know the
humans are still in the driving seat but
they're getting this support from you
know AI technology it seems to me that
while unemployment is I guess going to
happen there's no question you know it
seems the AI machine human interaction
keeps us Blackmoor in the loop for a
longer time and and for good reasons
because there many important problems
where for example I'm not really sure I
want to ready to I'm not yet ready I'm
not sure of any of you but I'm not yet
ready for a robotic caregiver when I
become old you know I still want like
soft and fuzzy human touching me kind
everything so I think it's like there
are things where you know that
collaborative aspects will basically
keep us more in loop London and so the
second I get positive okay so um the
quick comment you wanted to set the URL
there are thousands of URLs on all sides
of this question they're much as I need
to be just urgently right now Bolivia's
because I should comment is that there's
lots of uncertainty about about the
economic influences of various kinds of
advances
in machine intelligence technologies one
thing is certain though it's pretty
clear that these advances will lead to
trillions of dollars of resources
injected into our economy and the
questions would be how is that
distributed and how does the a I'm
making it somes influence that there's
recent National Academy of Science
report that though was published after
two years of intensive study and the the
key result of that the key guidance was
we need more data we need more
monitoring we need more tracking we're
flying in the dark so I'm not going to
try anything you read your url very
quickly but we could send it to me I'm
happy to look at it I think so I I'm not
sure what you meant but I want to pick
up on what eric just said and say I
think it's not just about jobs
okay Apia Rao mentioned I Arby's which
by the way you only have to get if
you're if you get it no not if you work
with people and you're at a company and
you don't take federal funds you don't
have to get an IRB but I know I know
Microsoft is a good citizen this regard
but certain other companies are but and
and here I think millons work actually
speaks to this it's also about the data
you collect and the communities you work
with and that we should be careful not
to be like the psychologist to use
sophomores at their universities as
their subjects and we should be careful
not only in whom we work with but also
when we give talks and put up slides of
the people we're studying they shouldn't
all look like Eric we should post more
letters Anna there's a problem I won't
make it well I'll take a few Eric's so
so I do I have a question so and that
was well commentary that we shouldn't
just don't get all about job obviously I
like collaboration working with people
is really really challenging and and
there are issues of privacy with respect
to data on the other hand sharing data
is really useful so just related to that
whole complex of things I wonder if you
have comments on how we can become a
stronger community in
sharing the data that we have and also
what we learn about how to do those
experiments will one comment I'll make
is that as well as many of us know and
they at community great leaps and
surprises have come of challenge
problems being defined in these days
more and more with with challenge
datasets we did Microsoft cocoa ms cocoa
it was common objects in context that
led to to to work at several sites and
in academic centers on image captioning
photo captioning wouldn't happen without
that as lab director at the time when I
was asked for a quarter-million dollars
and then by by larry zitnick at the time
and any double big one said half a
million dollars and both times I took it
out of my secret slush fund and said
this is really important let's go for it
and look what happened we had like like
was it within a year we had like New
York Times article was for senators
competing with you know similar similar
capability different approaches to it
then we had then we said that was a city
problem let's do this let's do you know
general FAQ questions and it went these
datasets are really critical for fuller
ation and they've always had been I
think we need to really invest there and
I think we will the partnership of
myglam will comment the parts of my I
has one of the goals of the partnership
and that Rao and I are part of is to
close the data divide between the large
companies that we can do a completely
but to address the gap between large
companies that have proprietary data
sets and other centers that might not
have access to those data sets and I
think that if we're trying to work these
solutions on that right now and there's
some interesting approaches so I guess
I'll make two comments first with
respect to sharing of data for on the
research side unless there's a reward
there's some reward system that we get
something out of this somebody who makes
such a data set public can publish it
get some public you know some credit for
a publication or something it's just not
not something somebody will do is you
know so
we understand that in other fields like
in conservation biology this is an
accepted practice not only you get
credit for the data but also even for
the R code or whatever that you share
and unless that become the standard
practice I don't see how I would advise
my students to say you know spend your
time trying to make this available and
so forth and that's something that we
need to grapple with and kind of
understand how that would happen but the
other part and it's a really wonderful
question here vizor some of these data I
mean we are we have to go out in the
field I mean some of this is very
unclean in some sense we don't quite
understand as we as a is going out into
society this is you know you're working
in let's say homeless shelter or in some
park in Africa the data is sort of very
unclean it's hard to know what what we
are getting there's all kinds of
restrictions and all sort and so there's
a whole I mean there needs to be some
kind of an understanding of how we
mature as a field to share such data and
what does that really mean it seems in
conservation biology that there's a lot
more of it there's a lot more
understanding of what all this means and
I mean I don't see that in our field yet
so so one thing in respect to you know
even though you made it probably partly
just this issue of having you know the
cultural mores taken into account when
you're setting up these kinds of
exchange is very important because I
think is a fascinating amount of work on
the acceptance of technology across
different cultures so you know in fact
even in the small experiments with
explicable 'ti and explanation that you
have done there are some people who have
the more of a mr. robot knows the
writing kind of an attitude and so for
everything robot does is explicable for
them you know essentially they're not
particularly questioning and there are
other people who are like more picky and
so in general essentially it is I guess
not it should not be surprising that
there is no such thing as a single human
you know and and so while we tend to
even getting these kinds of data it's
going to be an issue of it is just
personalized to one person or is it
personalized to particular groups and
something that we need to take index we
have to conclude the session very simple
path if you have like a quick comment oh
I just want to agree with Eric that it's
really important to frame the
conversation around disparities and AI
from multiple perspectives and jobs is
clearly just one dimension if you look
at healthcare alone whether it's
improving remote diagnosis for romic
rural medicine or actually even in the
home health scenario are subjects like
their robotic caregivers because they're
less embarrassing and they don't gossip
with the neighbors right so if you look
at shortage of home health workers and
possible disparities there so there's
there's many dimensions to societal
impact and increasing disparities around
this topic and it's important for our
community to keep framing it around
these larger issues can I invite people
to come into the session at 3:45 just a
continuation thank you to the speakers
[Applause]